n인데, 여기서 n은 F의 입력 문자열의 길이예요. 이제부터 대문자 N을 이 숫자, 즉 2의
소문자 n 제곱이라고 할게요. 사람들이 이런 식으로 대문자를 사용해서 소문자
버전의 2의 거듭제곱을 나타내는 건 꽤 일반적이에요. 대문자 N에 대해 꽤 많이 이야기할 거니까 이렇게 하면
편리하고 좀 더 깔끔하게 정리되겠죠. 그리고 이 표기법은
강의 전반에 걸쳐 적용돼요. 이제 물론 우리가 선택하는 어떤 순서로든 가능한 모든 n비트 문자열을 간단히
반복하여 각각에 F를 평가함으로써 탐색 문제를 고전적으로 해결할 수 있어요.
어느 시점에서 해를 찾으면 멈출 수 있지만, 최악의 경우 모든 단일
입력 문자열에 F를 평가하게 돼요. 그래서 이건 N, 즉 대문자 N번의
쿼리가 필요해요. 이 계산의 비용을 다른 방식으로 측정할 수도 있어요. 쿼리 횟수만이 아니라, 하지만 쿼리 횟수는
함수 f를 평가해야 하는 횟수를 나타내고, f의 평가가 비용을 지배할 것이라고 예상하는 게 합리적이에요.
이건 실제로 결정론적 알고리즘으로 할 수 있는 최선이에요.
다시 말하지만, 이건 쿼리 모델의 맥락에서예요. 만약 우리가 모든 입력
문자열 중 하나를 제외한 나머지를 모두 쿼리했고, F가 지금까지 그것들 모두에서 값 0을 취했다면, 마지막
문자열이 해가 아니라고 어떻게 확신할 수 있을까요? 답은 확신할 수 없다는 거예요. 그러니까 최악의 경우 N번의 쿼리가 모두
필요해요. 무작위성을 사용할 수도 있는데, 그건 해가 존재할 때 찾는 데 필요한
예상 쿼리 횟수를 줄이는 것과 같은 약간의 소소한 개선을 제공할 수 있어요. 또는 실제로 쿼리 감소를 위해 정확도
확률을 거래할 수도 있어요. 하지만 어떻게 접근하든 여전히 선형적인 쿼리 횟수가 필요해요.
N에서요. 그러니까 고전적으로 말하면 선형적인 쿼리 횟수, 즉
대문자 N에 대해 선형적인 쿼리가 필요해요. Grover의 알고리즘은 더 잘하는 탐색을 위한 양자 알고리즘이에요. 단지
N의 제곱근의 big-O 쿼리만 필요해요. 그 쿼리들은 중첩 상태에서 일어나니까 마법은 아니지만
고전적으로 가능한 것보다는 상당한 개선이에요. 이게 바로 이차적
이점이 의미하는 거예요. 고전 대비 양자의 이 이차적 이점이 실용적인 이점으로 전환될 수 있을까요?
가까운 미래에는 아마 아니겠지만, 먼 미래에는 모를 일이에요. 하지만 설령
Grover의 알고리즘이 탐색에 실용적인 이점으로 이어지지 않더라도, 그럼에도 불구하고 양자 알고리즘의
기초의 중요한 부분이에요. 잘 이해할 가치가 있죠. Grover의 알고리즘 자체로 넘어가기 전에
소위 위상 쿼리 gate에 대해 간략히 이야기해야 해요. 쿼리 모델의 많은 양자 알고리즘들이 자연스럽게
위상 쿼리 gate를 사용하여 표현되고, Grover의 알고리즘이 특정한
예시임을 알게 될 거예요. 먼저 우리가 이야기해온 형태의 함수 f에 대한 일반적인 쿼리 gate를 빠르게 살펴봐요.
쿼리 gate UF는 화면에 표시된 것처럼 표준 기저 상태에 대해 정의돼요.
그리고 표준 기저 상태의 중첩에 대해서는 작용이 선형성에 의해 결정돼요. 상기해 볼 가치가 있는 건
f에 대한 불리언 circuit에서 이 연산 UF를 위한 circuit을 실제로 만들 수 있다는 거예요. 비용은
불리언 circuit의 크기에 대해 선형이에요. 반면에 f에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate는
ZF라는 이름으로 나타내고 이런 식으로 작동해요. 특히 이 gate는
소문자 n개의 qubit에서 작동해요. UF와 달리 소문자 n+1개의 qubit이 아니라요. 기본적으로 함수 값을
추가 qubit에 XOR하는 대신 자동으로 위상으로 킥하죠. UF에서는
그렇게 했었죠. 그러니까 UF gate에 위상 킥백을 사용하면 어떻게 되는지 생각해보면
기본적으로 ZF gate를 구현하는 거예요. 마이너스 상태가 필요하고 UF의
평가 한 번이 필요하지만, 실제로 마이너스 상태를 되돌려 받아서 원하면 다음에 사용할 수도 있고
그냥 버릴 수도 있어요. 그게 위상 쿼리 gate예요. 만약 우리에게
위상 쿼리 gate ZF만 주어지고, 이게 함수 f에 접근하는 유일한 방법이라면, 실제로
UF gate를 복구할 수 없어요. 하지만 ZF의 제어 버전이 있다면
UF gate를 만들 수 있어요. 그건 연습 문제로
남겨 둘게요. 함수 f에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate 외에도 n비트
or 함수에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate도 필요해요. 다시 말해 이 함수는 all-zero 문자열이 입력될 때 값이 0이고, 그 외에는
값이 1이에요. 명시적으로 zor이 표준 기저 상태에서 어떻게 작동하는지는
화면에 표시돼 있어요. 이 gate는 함수 f에 의존하지 않으므로
아무 쿼리도 필요 없어요. 그리고 이 연산을 구현하는 양자 circuit을 만드는 한 가지 방법은 뭔가를 하는 거예요.
함수 f에 했던 것과 비슷하게요. 다만 n비트에 대한 or 함수를 계산하는 불리언 circuit으로 시작하는 거예요.
이제 이 gate들이 생겼으니 다음 섹션으로 넘어갈 준비가 됐어요.
이제 Grover의 알고리즘에 대해 논의할 거예요. 알고리즘 설명부터 시작해요. 소문자 n개의
qubit을 각각 플러스 상태로 초기화하는 것으로 시작해요. 다시 말해 이 qubit들을 길이 n의 모든
이진 문자열의 동등한 중첩 상태로 만드는 거예요. 우리가 할 건 이 qubit들의 상태를
해를 향해 효과적으로 유도하는 거예요. 그러니까 이 상태에서 시작하는 게 직관적이에요. 아직 함수 f에 대해 아무것도 모르니까요.
이 시점에서 모든 문자열이 해일 가능성이 동등해요. 그리고 이 qubit들이 모든 문자열의 동등한 중첩 상태에 있다는 사실이 그걸 반영해요.
그다음 반복해요. Grover 연산을 반복적으로 적용하는데, 이게 바로 알고리즘의
핵심이에요. 잠깐 후에 설명할게요. 이 연산을 총 T번 적용해요. T는 음이 아닌 어떤 정수인데,
이 숫자는 알고리즘 자체로 명시되지 않아요. 어떻게든 T를 선택해야 하고, 다음
섹션에서 T의 좋은 선택에 대해 이야기할 거예요. 하지만 지금은 이 반복 횟수 T를
임의적이라고 생각할 수 있어요. 마지막으로 표준 기저에서 측정하면
후보 해를 얻어요. 그게 실제로 해라는 보장은 없지만, T를 잘 선택하면
해를 얻을 확률을 크게 만들 수 있어요. 그리고 여기 Grover 연산이 있어요.